الصراع في السودان وصلت تاثيراته بالفعل
الى خارج حدوده ومساحته الجغرافيه في
الجانب الانساني نازحون ولاجئون الى دول
الجوار وايضا التاثير العسكري عابر لحدود
السودان بحسب تقرير لصحيفه جارديان
البريطانيه
التقرير قال ان حدود السودان تشهد حركه
قوافل شاحنات قادمه من ليبيا تنقل الوقود
من مصفاه بالقرب من مدينه الجوف الليبيه
بكميه تصل الى ما يعادل عشره الاف برميل
من النفط الليبي يوميا ويتم بيعها ثم
نقلها برا للسودان اضافه للوقود يتم تهريب
شحنات اخرى من الذخيره والاسلحه والادويه
للسودان لتغذيه النزاع هناك بينما تحصل
اطراف ليبيه على المقابل المادي جاردي
نقلت عن شهود عيان في مطار الجوف ان
امدادات تتضمن صواريخ كورنيت المضاده
للدبابات يتم نقلها جوا من الجوف الى
ولايه ومنها لعده ولايات سودانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن خبراء قولهم ان تجاره
الحرب هذه ليست بالجديده هو انها قائمه
لمده عقد او اكثر الا ان تاثيرها لن يكون
كبيرا لدرجه قلب التوازن القائم على الارض
وشدد الخبراء على ان النزاع والاضطراب
المرافق له سيمهد ارضيه من اجل الاستفاده
سياسيا من قبل عدد من القوى الدوليه التي
ستحاول ايجاد موطئ قدم لها في السودان
بينما تحاول دول اخرى تجنب التهديد الذي
قد يشكله اي انهيار في السودان على
مصالحها الخاصه حسن جوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات